Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show. I am Ferron Cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today. And what do
you say, folks? You ready for some non Donald
Trump news? Because I know.
Speaker 2: I sure am.
Speaker 1: So let's start with this. Two
individuals, Adam Fox and Barry Croft,
are now facing a maximum of life in prison after
a jury convicted them this week in their plot
to kidnap. Michigan governor. Gretchen Whitmer.
Now, this plot, I'm sure most people understand
and remember what happened, but just in
case you didn't, you had these individuals,
along with several other right wing extremists
that became so angry about Governor Whitmer's
COVID restrictions that they began plotting.
And the FBI actually had an informant within
their little group, a guy called Big Dan. Big
Dan is in their in their little extremist group
where they're plotting to go and kidnap Governor
Whitmer from her vacation home. And they had their
weapons. They were practicing with explosives.
Speaker 2: And that's also, by the way,
another charge that they received. But they they.
Speaker 1: Were going to do this. They were going
to overthrow the government of the state
of Michigan through this kidnaping plot.
This is actually the second time these
two men had been on trial. The first one
resulted in a mistrial because the jury obviously
could not come to any unanimous decision. And the
defense had done a fairly successful job of.
Speaker 2: Arguing, at least successful
in terms of the jury being hung there.
Speaker 1: Of convincing them that the FBI
set up basically entrapment for these
individuals. The FBI guy, Big Dan,
let's not disrespect Big Dan by calling him
anything else. Big Dan basically working for the
FBI convinced these men to do it right. If Big Dan
had been there pulling the little puppet strings,
they never would have thought about kidnaping.
Governor Whitmer. But this time around,
of course, the the jury said, no, you are
not making a convincing case that Big Dan.
Speaker 2: Is the guy responsible for this.
Speaker 1: So they got convicted again. They're
facing life in sentence, life in prison, excuse
me, as their sentence at a maximum. Now, here's
what drives me insane about this particular story.
These men wanted to kidnap and most likely kill
a democratically elected governor.
Because of COVID restrictions.
That's what this was over. That's what this
is about. And, yes, these individuals had,
you know, expressed anti-government
sentiment on social media for years.
Speaker 2: Which is one of the
reasons that the jury this time
didn't buy the FBI entrapment argument.
Speaker 1: But this was the last straw. Like,
how dare you? Try to take care of people during
a public health emergency, the likes of which
we have never seen in modern America. How dare
you tell us to wear masks? How dare you tell
us that we have to socially distance? I'm going
to kill you. Because you don't want me to die.
Because let's be honest, that's what this
was. That's what COVID restrictions were.
And we saw it across the country. Not kidnaping
plots, thank God. But we saw these lunatics
burning masks, getting children to throw masks
into burning trashcans, protesting over the fact
that we don't want you to die. But apparently
that's a bridge too far for these freaks.
Like you can't want to take care of
them. You can't want to protect them
because if you do, they may try to kill you. Can
you wrap your heads around that for just a moment,
folks? That's where we're at. That's what we have
come to. And of course, we're acting like Covid's
not still out there killing a couple thousand
people a week in this country, which it is.
We don't have any restrictions anywhere
anymore. You're free to do whatever,
but you're assuming the risks. And we still
have people out there trashing vaccines,
posting misinformation, ranting and raving about
non-existent COVID protection measures because,
again, they don't exist anywhere anymore. But
they're still mad. They're still protesting.
They're still acting like, Oh, my God,
this is terrible. This is tyranny.
All because some lawmakers, not even
all of them, but just some of them
actually wanted to protect their constituents
and not let them die from a deadly disease,
which at the time of the kidnaping plot, we
had no treatments for. We had no vaccines for,
we had no way to protect ourselves other than
wearing the masks and socially distancing and
avoiding unnecessarily large gatherings. That's
all we could do. We didn't have the packs loaded
pills. We didn't have vaccines. As I said, we had
nothing. We were throwing the spaghetti against
the wall when it came to treatment. That's why so
many people died. But I guess that's what these,
you know, extremists would have preferred.
Let me die. I'd rather die than have to wear
a mask. I'd rather kidnap the governor
of a state than not be able to go to
Chili's for drinks after work on Friday. That is,
unfortunately, the country that we live in today